why is it when a woman can't pay for her
child she gets government assistant but
when a man cannot pay for his child he
goes to jail
or gets his assets seized I'm not in
England though they get you get your
assets seized in England yes yes that's
because most men that have no access to
get seized that's why they get most men
with assets don't get the asses because
they become fathers I don't know I've
I've talked to a couple guys like
interviewing on the streets where yeah
yeah like I said it normally happens
more successful men not just right but
like I mean I understand but you're kind
of not answering the question is it
because of gender roles it's because men
are inherently seen and we are supposed
to be the providers women are the
nurturers
and as much as a feminist world we live
in they still in some of some so some
way except gender roles men are
providers so women are seen as the the
weaker sex the government the government
knows that they can uh there's more
money to be had of men than women yeah
because men make up the workforce so if
men wake up the workforce they
contributing the most to society
taxation wise and it's always a giveness
it's always going to be like that I
don't complain about it I just think
it's unfair we're gonna throw a caveat
in there and say between the ages of I
think it's 18 18 or 21 between the age
of 21 to 30 women aren't men yeah yeah
probably that like it goes back to my
point most men get into their Peak
potential earning in their mid-30s then
why is it being more conducive that
government focus on men when at a
certain proportion of time women
actually are earn money because women
because because women are bad with money
one makes 70 to 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions we hold two-thirds of
the world to die even though we make
more money we have less because from a
government standpoint that's a good
thing from a government's what do you
mean it hasn't spent expenditures
they're more likely to make money off
the people you spend money more
recklessly right but they're more likely
to be in debt yeah so when you're using
like taxpayer money
like like you have more money to go off
of yeah you have more that makes sense
it's a backward system clearly because
what you said what you say is true and
it's it's just that we have to accept as
a backward system and we just hope
Justice For Men you know fathers can one
day put it right I don't think it will
happen I just think I just think men
need to fix up see I don't see I don't
think it's a problem I think the problem
comes from where women try to strive for
equality yeah it goes back to the double
standards I will take the double
standards that benefit me yeah and
discard the rest yeah
I don't mind being a breadwinner I don't
mind having that responsibility likewise
to step up if you're pushing for
equality then you can't have that say no
more that don't make sense no it's so
good if a woman goes to work and owns
money so I'm very happy with that
believe me you go earn 50 of household
income combine that's 100 Grand a year
we are happy content we can do that from
home however however when you're trying
to be a man
don't be you just just don't try to be a
man because when men will always protect
you you will not protect the man regards
in any violent confrontations in life
ain't no female is going to protect the
man but do you think it's a side effect
do you think it's a side effect of women
earning as much as men that they now
think that they're equal
with men no people brainwashing people
we are two different creatures you have
biological Hardware well to male was
different and what industries do women
really out earn men in
what corn modeling
what industries do women out earn money
what what industries do women out earn
men in that don't have to do with health
and beauty yeah exactly sexualize only
the industries that sexualize their own
women I don't think that's the women's
fault I think it's the fact that men
have been in power for so long in such
high positions in these roles they find
it harder to give it to women and that's
a societal issue no women don't want to
know now women women women don't want to
do it women don't want to do those jobs
do you want to welcome
yeah yeah this is a high-paying job yeah
I personally don't want to do that do
you think women generally want to do it
but there's lots of high paying jobs
that women do want to do that's harder
for them to get to like I said do you
think women generally want to work on in
do you think women generally want to
work in the industries that are high
paying high hours high stress and high
tension do you think that's what the
type of Judge women generally want to do
I'm literally
High money high stress generally
right but you're you're not a doctor yet
but I'm sorry I understand you're
training to be a doctor but there's a
difference between training to be a
doctor and being a doctor and a lot of
times women get to a certain age and
they just see it's not worth it anymore
like I have a cousin and his his wife is
a doctor and she quit that [ __ ] because
she was like screw this I want to go be
home with my children and I think women
get to a certain age they just want to
be with their kids I don't think it's
Society I don't think it's a power thing
I just think they say screw this I make
enough money that's true I think this
was the the book affluenza where they
dictate the way they documented it where
they were looking at female lawyers and
say that in terms of the law profession
women are actually better than men but
the women will hit at age around the age
13 and just quit yeah and they will try
to retain these women they just don't
want to do it no more having babies in
there that's what they want I remember
there's a it was a beauty queen in
America this year
um Miss I think she was Miss America or
something like that
she very beautiful
um went to the highest Accolade of a law
profession in an American can give got
to I think she got to 30 was single and
she all of a sudden a law degree but the
reason why she stood out is because she
she ended up committing suicide and
I think she had a memoir or something
like that I'm not too sure but it was
supposedly due to the stress of
trying to obtain this uh law degree and
finally get in there and quitting
because her father was a lawyer
stepfather was a lawyer so I'm not
saying it contributes solely to build
the pressure she couldn't deal with the
pressure it contributed I don't know I
don't know if it contributes solely to
her demise but in so so somewhat way she
it was a metrics that she was trying to
reach out to I don't think ultimate
women find that real happiness in these
kind of jobs I think women find
happiness in family kids children
because when they reach a certain age
they don't want to do it anymore and and
we pick and we pick jobs that make less
money so like men are 23 more times more
likely to die in the workplace than
women we don't talk about that
inequality but we just want the pretty
positions at the top and say oh we want
to make as much money but we don't want
to do the things to get there like my
dad was the top half a percent earner he
worked 70 to 80 hours a week for 30
years I don't want to do that most women
don't want to do that and how would you
do that and have kids in a family it
just doesn't make sense sorry go ahead
um oh you know you just mentioned that
your you hopefully become a doctor
that'd be great for you honestly and
when you become a doctor the job
consists of a high intensity high
pressure a lot of hours
70 80 hours a week right yeah yeah I'm
on placement at the moment okay but you
will never die at work actually your
doctors have one of the highest suicide
rates yeah you can you can kill yourself
if you want but please don't because
we're not we're not like you're doing
this suicide on there you you will not
die because you're a doctor your patient
might because of your malpractice but on
oil rig you will die if you're not
careful
do you understand your mistake patient
dies my mistake in the Ulrich I die
people randomly die every day
that's that's a massive difference
between men's jobs and females jobs we
tend to lie we love putting our lives on
the line we love doing some dumb Mad Men
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible